first we want to tell you that today
marks the second day of Paul Manafort
trial in Virginia Manafort is charged
with tax evasion and filing false loan
documents the average sentence for tax
fraud in this country is a little over a
year in prison here in three months
Manafort is facing 305 years in prison
he is 69 years old he has never been
charged with a crime if he's convicted
in this trial Paul Manafort will die in
prison the left thinks that's just fine
Manafort Rand Donald Trump's
presidential campaign they believe he
deserves to die for that well watching
from the White House the president
tweeted this today about the trial quote
looking back on history who was treated
worse Alphonse Capone legendary mob boss
killer and public enemy number 1 or Paul
Manafort political operative and Reagan
dole darling now serving solitary
confinement
although convicted of nothing where is
the Russian collusion it's an
interesting point actually
Al Capone ordered the murders of scores
of people he got an 11 year sentence and
was released after just eight he was
barely 40 years old when he got a
president probably because he never made
the mistake of managing an unfashionable
political campaign the plan for Paul
Manafort meanwhile is to ensure that he
dies behind bars
Muller's lead prosecutor in this case
Andrew Weissman is working hard to make
sure that happens if you're at Hillary
Clinton's election night party in New
York City you may recognize Andrew
Weissman he was there too hoping to
celebrate Hillary's victory now he's
doing the next best thing
avenging Hillary's defeat keep in mind
that in America justice is supposed to
be evenly applied and maybe the best
thing about our country political
differences aren't supposed to get you
locked behind bars and then came the
resistance and everything changed
opposing Trump became a matter of total
war whatever it takes even if it means
corrupting our justice system and ending
a man's life